こんにちははじめ社長ですヘラクレス
日記12月編ですはい今年最後の
ヘラクレス大カブトに関する動画になると
思いますあらすじあるところにはみしちと
いうアホなYouTuberがいました
はみしちは角ミサイルが怖くて核
シェルターを700万円で買いましためで
出しめで出しと行きたかったところですが
はみ社長はそんな核シェルター買ったのに
全然使わねえせっかく買ったのに使い道
ないのはもったいないなと思いその格
ルターにヘラクレスカブのオスとメスを
ペットショップから買ってぶち込みました
700万円の虫かごの誕生ですカシルター
内はとっても快適ヘラクレスオカブトは
神尾をしまくりたくさんの子供を産みまし
たそして今12月になったわけなんです
けれどもま色々ありましたね半年ぐらい
申せしてるんですけれどもちょっとここ
最近冬に何があったかしっかり動画で記録
取っておりますのでぜひ見てみてく
ください
どうぞこんにちはヘラクレスベアです今が
10月の末10月の24日ぐらいです
かなり気温が寒くなってきてヘラクレス
ベアも暖房つけてま
2234ぐらいをキープしています幼虫も
ね大きいのはかなり育ってきました
ねまちょっと分かりづらいと思うんです
けどもめちゃくちゃでかく育っております
今日やりたいのは2つ1つがヘラクレスの
オスこちらにいますこちらヘラクレスの
オスのお部屋の移動をしたいなと思って
ますごめんねごめんなさいねメがもう死ん
じゃってしまって今酢1匹になってしまい
ましたでもう卵も生まれることがないので
こういうなんか卵用の土のスペースとかも
いらなく土があるとやっぱ小がどうしても
湧いちゃうのでであればコバが沸かない
なんかおが過ごしやすいスペースそして
かっこいいのでかっこいいのでこうシ
ケースみたいな場所にヘラクレスを移動
させせようかなと思っていますヘラグレス
の成虫の寿命成虫になってから大体半年
から1年ぐらいって言われててもう半年
経過しているのでまちょっといつ死ん
じゃうか分からないですけどもせめて死ぬ
までは過ごしやすいスペースでかっこよく
育てたいなと思いますはいでこんなケース
用意しましたのでここにちょっと移して
いきたいと思いますめっちゃかっこよく
ないですかようやく卵を産むフーズも
終わったということでせっかくこんな
かっこいい見た目だからかっこいいゲージ
で育てていきたいと思いますじゃあ早速
移動させていきましょうまずはずっと使っ
てた木はもうここに置いちゃい
ますヘラクレスも絶対慣れ親しんでるから
でヘラクレスちゃんももう先に移動させ
ますかっこいいできれば長生きして欲しい
ですね気に入ってくれるといいですけど
ごめんなさいふざけてこんなのも買ってき
ましたヘラクレスということでこう
ギリシャのこういうのも置いときますこう
いう高さのある植物も買ってみましたのり
移ってくれると一番いいんだけど
なこちらの木はいかがですか
微妙微妙ですか
ねあ行った行った行ったあ来た来た来たオ
オッケそれでいいんですさすが王者一応
この木も入れとき
ますあめっちゃいいじゃんいきなりそんな
てっぺん球に入れちゃったのねまた地面を
ちょっとしっかりしていきたいと思います
やっぱねコバエはどうしても湧きますねな
のでこういうあのコバエとかが気にくく
なるやつがあるのでこれちょっと巻いて
いき
ます
あとは自然感アくの歯ま意味あるんって
思いますけどせっかくだからさちょっとで
も自然は感じていて欲しいよねはいいいの
ではないでしょう
かはいというでヘラクレスの新しいお部屋
完成しました土がないということでかなり
すっきりしたのとやっぱコバがはきすぎて
て結構大変だったのでこれでま小の心配は
いらず過失さえしっかりしていれば問題
なく育てれるんではないかなと思います
いやめっちゃかっこいいなあとずっと上に
いるね君こう餌とかは結構パっとやり
やすいと思うのでかなり楽になったかなと
思いますあとはほと過失だけしっかりし
ないとね温度調節はばっちりなので過失
だけしっかりしていきたいと思いますはい
というわけで今日やりたかったもう1つの
こと7月2日に生まれた幼虫とかが4ヶ月
ぐらい経ったのでかなり大きくなってきて
ますでヘラクレスの幼虫って3例に分かれ
てて3連っていうか3段階初令
1番ちっちゃい頃で脱皮して2例でさらに
大きくなって3例ってこう3段階になんか
進化してくんですけど3冷幼虫ぐらい
大きくなるとその幼虫が押すか召すか
分かるようになりますでそれがちょっと
難しいんですけれども一応僕オスかメスか
の判別方法聞いてきたのでちょっと今日3
連幼虫何匹か出してみてそいつが果たして
オスなのかメスなのか見ていきたいと思い
ますちなみにオスとメスで全然変わってき
ます育て方オがめちゃくちゃ大きくなって
さぎの大きさとかもマジで次元違いになる
から容器の大きさとかもメスはそんな
大きくなくていいんですけどオスはね
大きいケースに入れないとさぎになる時角
がひん曲がったりするので結構ね押すか
メスかかなり大事ぽいですとりあえず
ひっくり返しますあもうでかすぎ
やろ後ろで弟が爆笑しとるいやもう
ちょっと今見て分かりました皆さん失礼し
ますはい
いやもう
ねもうやばいんですよサズ感がカブトムシ
の幼虫の規模ではないねすげえ3レ用地だ
とこんだけ大きくなりますでは見ていくぞ
ちょっとごめんねこれ触んなきゃわから
ないからちょっとだけ触らせていただき
ますあ潜ろうとしてるねごめんねちみに
もう昔使ってたちっちゃいスプーンとかと
比べるとこのサイズ感ですも乗りません
スプンには潜りたいとも失礼しますねじゃ
見ますえっと見るポイントがありますて虫
の
このああ動くね動くねごめんなさいね土
入りたいよねごめんねお腹のこの部分あ
そんな曲げたら分からないですよいい感じ
お腹のこの部分えっとねこれはねこの子
はちわかんないすね確かこの子オだった
はずですなんか前の写真あるんですけど
もこのここら辺に点みたいなちっちゃい点
がわずかに見えるんですよそれがあれば
押すなければメすっていう感じですま他に
もなんか頭の大きさとかで見れることは
できるらしいんですけど本当にこれどっち
だ失礼しますあ今めっちゃ見
やすいいやありそうか肉眼で確認し
ますないないあるちょっとすいません
わかりませんちょっとの余も見てみ
ましょうはいもう1匹行きましょうか7月
4日付のやつですま第1期生ですね一番
大きく育ってると思われますじゃ
ひっくり返しますここまで大きく育ってる
とちょっとなんか安心感があるんでか
ちょっとでかもう化け物でどドーナッツ
ぐらいあるけどね普通に失礼します見させ
ていただきますね眠そうだなごめん
ねここあごめんごめごめ
本当いっていって痛いちょっと待って
ごめんなさいいってい
[拍手]
て見たちゃんと感じもうここまで来ると
幼虫というかもう一種の生き物よね
ちょっとだけお腹の含見せていただきたい
んですけども患者様ちょっとだけお邪魔し
たいんですけどもあいいですかありがとう
ございます助かりますはいはい
はいあこれオスだこれオスですお腹の腹部
の下の方にテンって打ってやったんです
けどけどもあれがオスのマークらしいです
土とかかぶっちゃってプロの方でもたまに
分かりづらい時があるらしいのでま別に
分かっておいてもいいんですけど今すぐ
分かる必要もないぐらいけど早めに分かっ
た方が準備ができるのでこういう判別方法
で男の子が女の子が分かるよっっていう
紹介でし
たはいどうも11月の22日もうかなり外
は寒いですヘラクレスのお部屋はずっと
暖房をつけっぱなしでいますでねちょっと
ミスがあっ
てこれなミスって言えばいいんかな何なん
かな幼虫がですね1匹乾燥しちゃって死ん
でしまいましたこれ難しいんですけど普通
ねこういう容器でヘラクレス育ててるん
ですよ基本的にこういうもうヘラクレス
育てるよ昆虫の幼虫育てるようの容器で
育ててるんですがやっぱこの容器すごくて
水分がエアコンガンガンついてて乾燥し
てるはずなのに水分が逃げないようになっ
ててやっぱこのメッシュの素材とかいいん
だろうね虫が呼吸できるレベルのわずかな
穴しか開いてなくて湿度が保たれている
状態なんですすごいよね水滴空いて
るってことはやっぱ中がうってんのよなん
ですけどもこのねこのちっこいやつら最近
生まれた子たちはやっぱちっちゃいからさ
プリンカップにこういう穴を開けて呼吸さ
せるんですけどもこの穴がやっぱ大きいと
暖房切いてて乾燥して一気にもう土も
カラカラになっちゃってちょっと1匹
水分不足で死んじゃった子がいたので今回
はこのプリンクアップのやつらももうこう
いう容器に変えちゃおうかと思います感じ
なヘラクレスの成虫です
はいうん元気に起きてますねなんか元気
なかったけど復活したねうんそんなに湿度
がめっちゃ高いわけでもないんですけども
湿度が高すぎる場所よりかもなんか元気な
気がします頑張って大情して欲しいですね
うんゼリー食べてんのかな大幼女しろ
よ大女動けな撮影中だぞそして1個やばい
のがあるんですけどもこの月の4日7月頭
に生まれたやつの土の食べ方やばいんです
よ前満タンに入れたのにどんぐらいも1
ヶ月ぐらいかなももっと短いか前ね結構
入れたのに1ヶ月もしないうちにもう本当
今ちょうど半分ぐらいになっちゃいました
どんだけでかくなってんのっていう下にい
ますけどちょっと土追加するついでにどん
ぐらい大きくなったか見てみたいと思い
ますはいでは早速見てみましょうこの
大食いの個体です7月4日生まれのオス
ですねもうこいつはマジで巨大に育って
欲しいと思っ
てる繰り返しますどこにいるんだうわもう
いるいるいるいますぞ皆様さあ来いえ待っ
て待って本当に待ってちょっと待って待っ
て待って待ってちょっとちょっと待って
くださいちょっと待ってえいや怖い待って
こんなでかいことあるでかいのレベル超え
てるぞ
これうわ待ってで
かやばいやばいです皆
さん待ってすごないご覧ください皆様え
もう俺の指よりはかに俺めっちゃ手でかい
のよ俺の指よりはるかにでかいぞこれ
ちょっと待っ
[音楽]
てこれはでかすぎないですか奥さん
ちょっとこのでかさはすごいぞご覧
くださいあのなんて言うん
でしょうちょっと待って持ち方むずもう
本当に
でかいこのサイズ感ですよいやもう露骨に
でだっておもちゃやもんこれだけ見ると
でかくなりすぎ
でしょうもうここまで行くと多分もう強靭
な肉体の持ち主の腰痛ですね本当に
しっかり育てれば死ぬことはないと祈り
たい分からないので最初の注意は払います
がしっかりとえ土たくさん食べてたので
火水して水を超えた土を足してまた
たくさん食べてもらいたいと思います
じゃあ土足していきますたくさん食べて
大きく
なれもっとどれぐらいのサイズがいいん
だろうやっぱヘラクレスってさ日本の
カブトムシ絶対でかいわけなんでこの
サイズではまだ小さいのかもしれ
[音楽]
ないいいんじゃないかなはい皆さん覚え
といてくださいこんだけもう結構パンパン
に土入れてますもう本当にパンパンに入れ
てるんですけどもちょまた1ヶ月後どう
なってるか楽しみにしててくださいあとは
このプリンカップに入ってるちっちゃい
やつらを全部ちゃんとしたケースに移し
ます映していきます
ね
ちっちゃそっかちっちゃいよな
そりゃ
月めっちゃちっちゃいよ腹パンパンに食っ
て
[音楽]
オケーでかはないバグってる感覚がこれが
十字つい
たいやもっと小さいんだろうな11月うわ
ちっちゃ見てもう赤ちゃんおめでとう頑
カチLDKの部屋に引っ越し
[音楽]
あらこんにちは綺麗な体してるね
プリプリプリプリちゃん入るよ何言ってん
の俺あと2
個なんか顔
でか顔でかおば
さん黒いいんじゃないでしょう
かオッケーございますありがとうござい
ますはいこれで一通り終わりましたはい
プリンカップだった容器を全てこの多分
湿度が逃げにくい器に買えましたうん全然
変わりそうだけどねやっぱこういう水滴が
出てるか出てないかで土の中が湿ってるか
湿ってないかが結構分かりやすいと思い
ますこれで乾燥する冬の季節も
安心どうも11月の27日ですえの通り
ヘラクレスの幼虫めちゃくちゃ増えて
しまって容器も全部プリンクアップじゃ
なくてちゃんと幼虫育てるようの容器にし
たので場所が結構圧迫されたので棚を買い
ましたここに幼虫並べたら管理しやすいの
かなと思ってちょっとこれをカセルタの中
に入れていきたいと思います結構外寒いん
ですけども一応23°ぐらいでずっと
キープしてますてかヘバクレスってこんな
長気すんのねオスがねまだずっとなんか
元気でゼリー2個ぐらい食べちゃうす1日
ですごいな
な今朝だから寝てるのかなもう食べられた
からここゼリーにこう入れ替えて新しいの
にしたんですけどまだしばらく行きそう
ですじゃあ机を出していきますこの机も
良かったんですけどもやっぱこう棚に並べ
た方が絶対全部見えるから
ななるべく場所を圧迫しないように棚を
置いていきますでは棚入れていきますもし
自信が来てバンてなったらマジで終わり
です
なんかのなんか貼っとこうかな下
[音楽]
によしめっちゃいいんじゃねでは早速置い
ていこうと思いますもう計算してこの棚
買ったのよ奥行のここの長さがこれより
2cm
大きい完璧に置けますこれこれでカ
シェルターを広く使いながら幼虫の世が
できるという状況になりましたあ卵から
浮かした秘で置いていき
ますはい一応並べることができました結構
まだ余裕がありますねいやこれめっちゃ見
やすいでしょうもうすぐにいもでか結構
一目瞭然で土の減り方とか幼虫の様子が
分かるのでとてもいいんじゃないかと思い
ますみんな今寝てるねはいただこっちも
めっちゃあるんだよなもう本当に幼虫が多
すぎて大変ですでもこれで見やすく管理
できると思い
ますはいいかがだったでしょうかすごく
ないですかたくさんいた幼虫しっかり育っ
てきて
ます化け物化け物みたいに育ってるやつも
いたりでも中にはなんか思ったより育って
ないなっていう子もいましたしいろんな土
を試したりしてるからなんか個体さはあり
そうなんですけどそれでもしっかりと用途
育ってますちょっと冬心配だったのよ寒い
からなんかちょっと冬によくカブトムシの
見せるイメージがあったからちょっと
乗り越えられるかどうか心配だったんです
けども今のところ無事にスクスク大きく
なってプリンカップで育ててたやつがもう
めちゃくちゃでかいケースに入れれるよう
になってお部屋も改造してこう容器を
ずらっと並べるとすげえこんなに命を育て
てるんだと実感を持ちましたこっからどう
なるんだろうなさぎまでまだしばらくなら
ないと思うんですよ幼虫期間が続くんです
けどヘラクレスカブトの大きさって幼虫の
時の大きさに決まるんですよさぎになっ
たり成通になってからもう大きさは全く
変わりません全く成長しないらしいのよ
幼虫の時にいかに大きくぶっくこやすこと
ができるのかがポイントらしいのでえ今後
もしっかりとねあの土をしっかり食べさせ
て温度調節湿度管理頑張っていきたいと
思いますあとどうするかなあんなたくさん
いて全部成長になってもお世話できないん
だけどあの欲しい人いたらよかったら
コメント欄で教えてくださいそれではまた
来年も初め方の隠しルタヘですお楽しみに
じゃあな
[音楽]
OG